[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه التاسعه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
[موسيقى]
الدفاع الروسيه
وكيف تتهم موسكو بتعمد قصف المدنيين
استخبارات والمانيا تحذر مواطنيها ذوي
الاصول الايرانيه من عواقب وخيمه في حال
السفر لطهران
بيونج يونج تستفزه واشنطن بتعزيز النهائي
لتراسان النوويه وكوريا الجنوبيه تتاهب
لحرب محتمله
صندوق النقد الدولي يصدموا العالم كارثه
اقتصاديه هذا العام بسبب اصابات كورونا في
الصين
[موسيقى]
البدايه مشاهدينا من تطورات الحرب في
اوكرانيا اعلنت كييف ان موسكو تستهدف
المدنيين لانه لم يعد لديها اي اهداف
عسكريه كما اكدت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان
الاضرار التي لحقت بمرافق ومنشات البناء
التحتيه للطاقه في البلاد وصلت الى مستوى
غير
مسبوقتا ان هذا الضرر الهائل سيستغرق
شهورا ان لم يكن سنوات لاصلاحه واستعاده
عمل شبكه الكهرباء بالكامل رغم كل ذلك اكد
الجيش الاوكراني انه مستعد لكل احتمالات
والتصعيدات الروسيه
الوضع الان متوتر الى حد ما لان العدو
الشديد العدواني وماكر للغايه من وجهه
نظري لا ينبغي لاحد ان يقلل من شان العدو
يعدونا كل انواع المفاجات السيئه كل يوم
التقى
لم استطع البقاء في المنزل لقد تم تعبئه
ابن فتطوعت الوضع صعب للغايه لديه اصابه
في الدماغ وهو يعالج في مستشفى دنيترو
صناعه
الاصدقاء والاحتفال اجبر الناس على البحث
عن ماوى قتل بعضهم
ان بعض جنودنا قتلوا على خط المواجهه
اليوم كما قتل شخص في كيف ايضا هذا محزن
انه محزن للغايه انها ماساه كبيره لا يمكن
التغاضي عنها هذا هو السبب في ان ليله راس
السنه الجديده حزينه
هذه التصريحات
الاوكرانيه يقبلها تصريحات روسيه وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت على استهداف مصانع
عسكريه اوكرانيه تستخدم لانتاج المسيرات
وبصواريخ دقيقه بعيده المدى كما كشفت عن
تدمير مستودعات ومراكز اطلاق المسيارات
وقالت الدفاع الروسيه انها افشلت محاولات
لكيف للقيام بهجمات ضد اراضيها كما اشارت
الى انها احبطت محاولات اوكرانيه للتوغل
في جنوب دونيت
القوات المسلحه الروسيه ضربه باسلحه جويه
بعيده المدى عاليه الدقه على مرافق المجمع
الصناعيه العسكري لاوكرانيا والمتورط في
تصنيع طائرات هجوميه بدون طيار تستخدم في
تنفيذ هجمات ارهابيه ضد القوات الروسيه
كما اصيبت مرافق التخزين ومواقع اطلاق
الطائرات بدون طيار وقد تعطلت خطط نظام
كيف لتنفيذ هجمات ارهابيه وشيكه ضد
الاتحاد الروسي في المستقبل القريب
مع تصريحات لقائد مرتزقه بعد ماريا
بريكوجين الذي قال ان المجموعه العسكريه
الروسيه اثرت عددا كبيرا من جنود الجيش
الاوكراني واضافه في تصريحات اللي وكاله
نفي اقر بشده المقاومه لدى الجيش
الاوكرانيه قائلا انا من بين هؤلاء الاسرى
عدد كبير من من اصيب واضطر للاستسلام
وهناك من قاتل حتى النهايه اضطر للخروج
وايديهم مرفوعه من اجل انقاذ حياتي رفاقهم
هذا وقد كشف الجنرال الامريكي المتقاعد عن
ان درسنت روسيا بدات تعاني من نقص متزايد
في الاسلحه التي يحتاجها بوت في الحرب ضد
كيف مارك هرتن لينك الذي شغل سابقا منصب
القائد العام للجيش الامريكي في اوروبا
قال لمجله نيوز ويك ان الجيش الروسي باتي
يفتقده الذخيره وانواع من الاسلحه هي ما
الصواريخ البالستيه اضافه الى صواريخ
منظومات الدفاع الجويه من طراز 300 مضيفا
ان بوتن حريص جدا على بناء علاقات مع دول
مثل ايران والصين في محاوله للحصول على
مزيد من الامدادات العسكريه من هنا هناك
المزيد ينضم الينا من دونيتك مراسل
العربيه رائد الاكبر اهلا بك رائد اخر
التطورات الميدانيه
القذائف والصواريخ على مقاطع
عنيفه والقصف متبادل حقيقه للشفافيه
الحديث عن اعداد كبيره من الصواريخ تسقط
زخات كل 10 دقائق في احياء متفرقه من
المدينه وفي البلدات المتاخمه للمدينه
ايضا نتحدث عن مدينه
كان الحديث في الصباح عن بعض التقارير
التي اشارت اليها القياده العسكريه
للقوات الشعبيه في مقاطعه قالوا بان هناك
اسلحه غربيه حديثه العهد لم تدخل في
المعارك سابقا همم اليوم تم الاعلان عن ان
هذه هي راجمات صواريخ التشكيه الصنع تسمى
بامبير
وتطلق عشرات الصواريخ همم تصل الى بعد يصل
المدى الى 40 كيلو متر وتحمل رؤوس خارقه
لتخترق الجدران والدروع على غرار او على
خلاف الصواريخ السابقه التي كانت على سبيل
المكال صواريخ اجراءات كانت تطلق
وتنثر الشضايا
لقتل المتواجدين
او ما تسمعوه انه بالفعل هناك تغير في
نوعيه الاسلحه المستخدمه وبالتالي
استمراريه هذه المواجهه وبالمقابل هناك
تصريحات امريكيه ذكرناها قبل قليل انه
تقرير تتحدث عن نقص من همم الجانب الروسي
فيما يتعلق بالاسلحه والامدادات
ربما تقير التقارير الامريكيه ليست حديثه
هذا هذا الامر يعرض كل يوم لكن روسيا تؤكد
انها يعني مستعده
لتغطيه العمليه العسكريه بكم هائل من
الاسلحه نحن نعلم عن طريق مصادرنا الخاصه
بان مصالح مصانع الاسلحه الروسيه اصبحت
تعمل على مدار ال 24 ساعه ثلاث شتات يعني
ثلاث دورات كل ثمان ساعات فريق يعمل
لتغطيه ال 24 ساعه لكن دعيني اعرج على
مساله همم تصريحات الاوكرانيه والتي تقول
بان الجيش الروسي يستهدف المدنيين قالت
الدفاع الاوكرانيه وقالت مصر تحديدا
والقياده العسكريه بان الجيش الروسي
يستهدف مواقع عسكريه حسره ومصانع للاسلحه
والذخيره ومراكز لاصلاح الاليات العسكريه
واضافت ان همم يعني الدفاعات الجويه
الاوكرانيه التي تح الاعتراض الصواريخ
الروسيه تفشل يعني تفشل في اصابه اهدافها
وتسقط على المدنيين والموقع
سؤال اخير فيما يتعلق بالنازحين هل من
ملاذ امن لهم
حمله نزوح كبيره ميسون من مدينه دانيست
تحديدا بدا الناس ينزحون الى المناطق
الجنوبيه الى النظافه
الاوكراني يستهدف هذه المناطق ولم يتوقف
منذ الصباح الباكر ومنذ 48 ساعه كان القصف
عنيف جدا ربما الناس القسم متبادل
للشفافيه ميسون لكن بالفعل المرحله خطيره
جدا
وعمليه النزوح لا تشمل وحده هناك في منطقه
في اخرصون انقطاع لتيار الكهربائي ونصحت
السلطات هناك المواطنين ايضا بالنزح الى
والبلدات الاقرب التي فيها خدمات كهربائيه
ايضا هناك في منطقه زبروجيت تعرض مدينه
اندردار التي تحوي المنشاه النوويه لقصف
اوكراني حسب السلطات المحليه
[موسيقى]
الى ملف الاحتجاجات في ايران نشدت
الاستخبارات الداخليه الالمانيه ذوي
الاصول الايرانيه ناشدت المعارضين الى
توخي الحذر حال رغبتهم في السفر الى ايران
اكدت الاستخبارات الالمانيه ان على ذوي
الاصول الايرانيه المعارضين توقعوا وعواقب
وخيمه قال رئيس الاستخبارات الالمانيه ان
المشاركين في تظاهرات التضامن مع ايران
السابقه
والتقطوا صورا ومقاطع فيديو لبعضهم
ونشروها على مواقع التواصل ما سهل على
الاجهزه الايرانيه تحديدا هويتها
من جانبها اكد رئيس نقابه اجهزه الاتصالات
في طهران دخول 800 جهاز ستار لينك الى
ايران بحسب طبعا موقع ايران انترناشونال
ويتزمن هذا التصريح مع اعلان لالم ماسكه
الرئيسيه التنفيذي للسبيس اكس عن تنشيط
100 جهاز ستار لينك للانترنت الفضائي في
ايران كانت صحيفه وستريد جورنا كشفت عن
تهريبه 200 جهاز الى البلاد منذ بدايه
الاحتجاجات بسبب القيود التي فرضها النظام
الايرانيه على الانترنت
وكانت وكاله انباء فارس نقلت عن مسؤول
كبير في الشرطه الايرانيه عوده الرسائل
النصيه التي تتعلق بالحجاب الالزام الى
اصحاب السيارات نقل موقع ايران
انترناشونال عن الوكاله ان المرحله
الجديده من مشروع ناظر واحد قد بدات في
جميع انحاء ايران بحسب الضابط وقالت
الوكاله ان رسائل نصيه سترسل لتذكره
لاصحاب السيارات التي يتم فيها الكشف عن
الحجاب تشير تقارير على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعيه الى عوده شرطه الاخلاق في
شوارع طهران كان النائب العام الايراني
قال في وقت سابق انه تم تعليق نشاط شرطه
الاخلاق المتهمه بالتسبب في مقتل الفتاه
الكرديه
هذا ويوصل النظام الايراني نصب المشانق
بحق المحتجين ولا معارضين حيث اصدرت محكمه
ايرانيه في مدينه شهر بمقاطعه مازن داران
في ايران الحكم على شيان محمد بالاعدام
بعد اعتقاله في الثاني من اكتوبر من العام
الماضي بعد عودته من احدى الاحتجاجات
نبقى مشاهدينا في ايران ايضا نهج سكات
الافواه وايضا قطع الانترنت لعدم وصول ما
يجري في الشارع للخارج هو تكتيك متبعه على
مدى سنوات في ايران اليوم هناك خطه مدروسه
من المتوقع ان يصادق البرلمان عليها وتهدف
الى تجريم تصوير الاحداث ونشرها على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي جمعيه الصحفيه في طهران
حذرت من خطه المتابعه القانونيه والقضائيه
للاخبار الكاذبه في الفضاء السيبراني
ومشروع قانون في الحكومه وذلك بعنوان
قانون الصحافه الشامل بمعنى ان اي تصوير
لمسرح الجرائم او نشر او اعاده نشر لقطات
او صور مسجله تم اعدادها بشكل غير مرخص
سيعاد بهذا الاطار جريمه يحكم على مرتكبها
بالسجن وذلك من الدرجه الخامسه الخطه وضعت
باخانه تجريم العمل الصحفي وتقييد انشطه
الصحفيين والمواطنين الصحفيين البلد يحتل
اسوا المراتب في مؤشر الصحافه العالميه
لاسيما مع ازدياد عدد الاعتقالات
والاذانات التعسفيه وسجن الصحفيين وايضا
من حرمالهم من الرعايه الطبيه جمعيه
الصحفيين اعلنت ان الحكومه والبرلمان
يعتزمان المصادقه على هذه الخطه والمشاريع
ولكن سرا وذلك لعدم اتاحه اي مجال امام
ردود الفعل الرافضه طبعا وفقه تعبيرها
[موسيقى]
يا جوجو
الايراني
تحيه طيبه لك يا استاذه ميسون وكل عام
وحضرتك ومشاهدين
الواقع بان هذا ان دل على شيء بدايه يدل
بان المواطن
الصحفي كما يقال ويعرف في ايران اييي اوجع
النظام واستطاع ان يغطي ااا يغطي الاحداث
بشكل كبير جدا خاصه ونحن يجب ان نعلم بان
مرجعيه الاعلام الفارسي لم تعد داخل همم
النظام او داخل ايران بلد تحولت الى خارج
البلاد وبالتالي هي من تؤثر همم تاثيرا
بالغا في همم اجاده التصورات وايجاده همم
الرؤى كما يعتقد النظام الايراني من هنا
اعتقد بان هذه الخطوه في جانب منها تشير
الى هذه الامر اما الجانب الثاني وهو
الاهم ربما
اعتقد يعبر عن تخبط النظام الايراني
بكيفيه التعامل مع هذه الاحداث الكبرى
وهذا الحراك الثوري لذلك هو من جانب يضيق
الخناق يدعو اليه
لانه بالسابق كان في حديث كثير عن قضيه
استهداف هؤلاء الصحفيين المواطنين ومن ثم
ربما هناك نوع من الوعي ان ذلك لا ينفع
وبالتالي علينا السير بالقطر القانونيه
اذا ما صح التعبير
يعني نحن اذا ما اخذنا بعين الاحتبار مثلا
ايه التصنيف العالمي للصحافه في ايران
فاعتقد بان ربما هي الرؤيه الاولى هي التي
تكون الراجحه بمعنى ان هذه الخطوه هي ضمن
التخبط وضمن تضييق الخناق وليس ضمن ربما
تصويب التي يدعي بها النظام الايراني
التصريحات الايرانيه الان همم وحتى
الاحتغالات التي تجرى مثلا لبعض المواطنين
من مزدوجين الجنسيه وخاصه البريطانيين
تشير بان هنالك خشيه كبيره جدا من الاعلام
ومرجعيه الاعلام الفارسيه التي باتت في
الخارج ولم تعد الداخل
من خلال نشر هذه المعلومات احراج همم امام
المجتمع الدولي ام ماذا
الواقع عده امور حدثت بهذا الاطار اولا
ااا الواقع بان هذه الثوره وهذا الحراك
الثوري هو معقد ومركب بمعنى ان انه استطاع
ان يعمل على المجال السوشيال ميديا وكذلك
على ان يكون ذات رسائل الى الدول
المختلفه وكذلك الفاعلين السياسيين اضافه
الى استطاع ان يوجه او يسقط هيبه النظام
الايراني وهيبه المرشد الايراني
داخليا وخارجيا لذلك فيما يبدو بان النظام
الايراني الان باتيت يدعو الى مصطلح يدعو
الى جهاد التبيين كما يسميه وهو يدعو الى
ان يكون تصور اخر يواجه هذا التصور لايجاد
او عوده المرشد الايراني
اذا كان المقصود في مجال
النظام الايراني اعتقد بان الان كل الامور
تشير وكل يعني المعالم
وربما
يعني العناصر والعوامل تشير بان النظام
الايراني لن يستطيع ان يتعامل او يخنق هذا
الخناقه همم الذي حدث وبالتالي الشعب
الايراني يعلم بان من يعمل نصف ثوره كما
يحفر قبره بنفسه بالتالي يجب ان يمضي بهذه
الطريقه
مناسب على رؤيه
سكوتي
افادت قناه ايران انترناشونال حجم
الانترنت في ايران ادى الى خسائر ماليه
ضخمه لمشغيل الهاتف المحمول وايضا الشركات
التي ياتي دخلها الاساسي من استهلاك الناس
للانترنت واكلته انباء الطلبه الايرانيه
اثناء
خمس شركات ايرانيه كبرى للاتصالات تكبدت
مليارات التومنات من الخسائر ووصلت الى
حافه الافلاس منذ الشهر الاول من
الاحتجاجات بحسب خطاب ارسلته شركات بنات
الى هيئه الاتصالات الرسميه فقد تضررت
بنحو 10 مليارات ومان اي ما يعادل 25% من
دخلها فيما خسرت شركه ايران سيلف 800
مليار تومان اما شركه اتصالات رايتل
فتكبدت خسائر بمستوى 30 مليار توماس
ونبقى في الملف الايراني ففي ظل ضغوط
سياسيه داخليه وايضا ازمات اقتصاديه طاحنه
تبدي ايران استعدادها لاحياء مفاوضات
الاتفاق النووي في في وقت صرح فيه مسؤول
امريكي لموقع جده ايران ان الساسه
الايرانيين قتلوا اي فرصه لعوده سريعه
للالتفاق النووي
2022 الايراني ودائعه للعام الجديد في
طهران احتجاجات داخليه عقوبات اوروبيه
اساسها القامه ضد المحتجين
التي شكلت ريهانا كبيرا على الخروج من عنق
زجاجه الازمه الاقتصاديه
حمل في هذا السياق مسؤوليه مراوحه
المفاوضات النوويه للسلطات الايرانيه وفق
موقع اجاده ايران مشيرا الى ان طهران قتلت
حدود العوده السريعه الى الاتفاق النووي
بسبب رفضها المتكرر للمقترحات المعروضه
عليها خلال العامين الماضيين لكن بالنسبه
الى المسؤولين الايرانيين فلديهم رؤيه
سياسيه مختلفه عبر عنها في اكثر من مناسبه
وزير الخارجيه حسين امير عبد الله الفرصه
هتقول لي اتخاذ الخطوات النهائيه لاحياء
الاتفاق النووي لكنها لن تبقى كذلك للابد
لكن خلف تعثر بيا عده حقائق فرضتها عوامل
بعضها قديم واساسي وبعضها الاخر مستجد في
العوامل القديمه اصرار ايران على غلق ملف
التحقيق باثار اليورانيوم في عده مواقع
نوويه يقابله اصرار من الوكاله الدوليه
بمواصله التحقيق وانتظار اجوبه واضحه من
منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه في العناصر
الجديده انزلاق ايران او تورطها في تسليح
روسيا بالمسيرات في حربها على اوكرانيا
ايضا برز موقف امريكي جديد نقل الاولويه
من مفاوضاتهم الى احتجاجات ايران واشنط
ستركز جهودها على امدادات الاسلحه
الايرانيه الى روسيا وعلى دعم المتظاهرين
بدلا من التركيز على المحادثات النوويه
المعطله التي لا نعرفها فائدتها
حاله عدم يقين سياسي تترافق مع تازم
الاقتصادي ضاغط وتدفع الاحتجاجات
والاضرابات الى التحول الى مشهد دائم في
المدن الايرانيه طالب تبدا بشعارات الحريه
والانتفاضه على النظام وتمر بالتضخم
والوظائف والاجور كالملف النووي تبقى
معلقه بلا اجابات او معالجات مستدامه
[موسيقى]
ثلاثي لوزراء خارجيه التركيه وسوريا
وروسيا هذا الشهر
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا وفي خطوه تقارب جديده
يعتزم كل من وزراء خارجيه تركيا والنظام
السوري وايضا روسيا لاجتماع قريبا في
موسكو طبعا هذه اللقاءات الاخيره باتت
تشغل السوريين في شمال البلاد اكثر من
القصف والجوع والنزوح وقساوه الشتاء عوده
المناطق الى سيطره النظام وفق ما وعدت به
انقره تشكل كابوسا لسكان الشمال
والمعارضين هناك لان ذلك يعني التنازلات
كبيره ستاتي على حسابهم اللافته في الامر
هو الثلاثه التي تنتهجها انقر في
استداراتها السياسيه نحو النظام الاسد دون
ان يكون الارتباطاتها المتينه مع المعارضه
السوريه ايت موانع كما بدا طبعا وهنا ياتي
السؤال الذي يشغل بال المعارضه السوريه
حاليا وفقه وسائل الاعلام محليه هو ماذا
ستحصل تركيا مقابل كل هذه التنازلات وما
الذي يضمن لها تحقيق مصالحها في سوريا اول
ما تريده انقره هو او ما هو واضح على
الاقل يتجسد فنانات يقدمها نظام الاسد
بابعاد المقاتلين الاكراد عن حدودها ونصف
اي مشروع قومي كردي في الشمال السوري لكن
ماذا عن الوجود الامريكي في المنطقه خصوصا
وان واشنطن لم تبدي اي موافقه قويه حتى
الان من التقارب التركي مع الاسد سوى
تصريح ممدد بالرغم من ذلك الا ان مسؤولين
اكراد عسكريين وسياسيين ما زالوا واثقين
من ان امريكا لن تسمح باي اثر هذا التقارب
على الاداره الذاتيه الكرديه في المنطقه
وقوتها
متى يجتمع الرئيس التركي بنظره السوري
سؤال باتت اجابته تقترب اكثر من اي وقت
ففي مسار خريطه الاتصال بين انقره ودمشق
يبدو ان القطار التطبيع ماض في سكته وهي
خريطه طريق ترتكز على عده محطات
الاسبوع الماضي شهد لقاء غير مسبوق منذ 11
عاما يجسد خطوات مهمه في التقارب التركي
السوري فبعد لقاء وزراء دفاع تركيا وسوريا
وروسيا في موسكو بمشاركه قاده اجهزه
الاستخبارات كشف وزير الخارجيه التركي عن
اجتماعا مع نظيره السوري والروسي منتصف
يناير الحالي مشيرا الى انه قد يعقد في
بلد اخر تقارب متسارع وتفاصيل تتكشف عن
اللقاء الثلاثي الاخير فتركيه وافقت على
الانسحاب الكامل من الاراضي في الشمال
السوري واكدت على احترامها وحده وسلامه
الاراضي السوريه في الاجتماع ايضا عن قرا
اكدت انها تعد ترحب باللاجئين السوريين
فعودتهم كانت على راس الملفات اجتماع
موسكو بحث ايضا وفق مسؤول تركي لرويترز
امن الحدود والعمل المشترك بين انقره
ودمشق لمواجهه ومكافحه ما وصفه المسؤول
بالارهاب الذي تمثله قصد وداعش وباقي
التنظيمات صحيفه الوطن السوريه المقربه من
النظام اكدت نقلا عن مسؤولين سوريين ان
الاطراف اتفقت على اعتبار حزب العمال
الكردستاني مليشيا عميله للولايات المتحده
واسرائيل وتشكل خطرا على سوريا وتركيا
تفاهمات القت بظلالها على شمال سوريا حيث
رفض المسؤولون الاكراد المحليون مخرجات
لقاء موسكو الثلاثي وعوده النظام ممددين
بما اعتبروه منحه الشرعيه للنظام
كيف يتم التعاطي مع هذا التقارب التركي
السوري في هذه الفتره تحديدا وخاصه في ظل
الحديث عن الاجتماع المرتقى بالوزراء
الخارجيه
نعم سنبدا بدايه بجانب التركي قبل ان
اتحدث عن رده فعل الشارع السوري المعارض
وكما عرضتم في التقرير المظاهرات التي
اندلعت في الشمال بدايه تركيا تبحث من هذا
التقارب مع دمشق على على اهداف محليه
قصيره الامد واهداف مستقبليه بعيده الامان
الاهداف المرحليه تتمثل وهي اهداف
انتخابيه بحث باجراء لقاءات علنيه مع
مسؤولين من النظام السوري وفي حال توفره
الارضيه وهذا ما يبدو ان الامور تسير
باتجاهه اجتماع بين الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان مع رئيس النظام السوري بشار الاسد
قبل موعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه القادمه همم
اهميه هذه الخطوه بالنسبه للمسؤولين
الاتراك هي اعطاء رساله لشارع التركي
والنقلين الاتراك بان حكومه العداله
والتنميه برئاسه تريد حل قضيه اللاجئين
التي تاتي في مراتب متقدمه ضمن اولويات
ومشاكل التي يراها الشارع التركي انها
موجوده ح- موجوده حاليا في البلاد بعد
المشكله الاقتصاديه التي تحتل المرتبه
الاولى ومن ثم مشكلات اخرى كمشكلات
الحريات وتراجع الحريات في البلاد وايضا
قضيه اللاجئين قضيه قويه جدا هذه القضيه
تستغلها المعارضه التركيه لمصلحتها بقوه
وكان تضغط على حكومه العداله والتنميه منذ
عام 2013 وليس الان لكن همم الاوضاع نتحدث
عن نسب التاييد في الشارع لحزب العداله
والتنميه وتحديدا في هذه القضيه تراجعت
مؤخرا وخلال السنوات الماضيه رجعت بشكل
كبير وكل همم استطلاعات الراي تشير لان
هذه القضيه ربما تشكل تهديدا حقيقا في
صناديق الاقتراع لذلك الاهداف المحميه
التركيه والرئيس اردوغان انت تقول انه
الوضع الان اصبح احسن في ظل طرح هذا
الموضوع بالنسبه للحزب الحاكم وكيف تتعامل
المعارضه مع ذلك يعني على حساب المعارضه
سيكون ذلك
همم لا شك ان هذا الموضوع المعارضه كانت
هي التي تعهدت بانها ستعيد العلاقات مع
النظام والتوعيد فتح السفاره التركيه في
دمشق وايضا تعيد اللاجئين لذلك هذه الورقه
الان يتم سحبها تدريجيا من المعارضه
لمصلحه حكومه العدل العداله والتنميه
والائتلاف الحاكم ما بين حزب العداله
والتنميه وحزب الحركه القوميه تعتقد همم
الحكومه التركيه ان في حال نجحت في هذه
الخطوه همم وهي موضوع اللقاءات حتى يعني
فقط اللقاءات مع مسؤولين سوريين مسؤولين
النظام السوري ربما تقنع الشعره بانها
قادره على اعاده اللاجئين وحل مشكله
اللاجئين خلال الفتره القادمه همم هذه هي
الاهداف المرحاليه القصيده الامل الاهداف
المستقبليه اليوم همم لا شك ان انقره تدرك
جيدا انه مهما ارتفع حجم او مستوى
اللقاءات لا يمكن حل المشكله السوريه
ومشكله اللاجئين السوريين الموجودين هنا
في تركيا بهذه اللقاء دون وجود اطراف
فاعله اخرى في المشهد السوري وتحديدا
الولايات المتحده
الاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا الامم المتحده
لذلك هناك قرارات اميه يجب ان تطبق وتعلم
انقر جيدا ان هذه القرارات في حال طبيقات
يمكن همم عوده اللاجئين من خلالها وممكن
تطبيق او ممكن حل جزء كبير من المشكله
السوريه لكن مستقبلا في حال طبقت هذه
القرارات وحتى الوصول الى هذه المرحله
تريد انقر الحصول على مكاسب مستقبليه
المكاس المستقبليه تتضمن بدايه
التطوير اتفاقيه اضنه التي وقعت مع النظام
السوري عام 1998 وتسمح لي انقره بالتدخل
بعمق خمسه كيلومترات داخل الاراضي السوريه
في حال ما همم اعتبارات انقره ما وجود خطا
يمثل تهديدا على امنها القومي وهنا تشير
انقر الى حزب العمال كردستاني حاليا انقره
تريد همم تطوير هذه الاتفاقيه الى مدى
اعمق من خمسه كيلومترات الجنه همم
المساحه او المسافه المقترحه من انقره هي
30 كلم هذا الجانب همم
ما يتعلق وتفاقيه امامنا ايضا هناك مكاسب
اقتصاديه تريد انقر تحصيلها من خلال تطوير
علاقاتها او تطبيع علاقاتها مع النظام وهي
بدايه تاريخ
اسطنبول مراسل العربيه زيدان زين كلو
المزيد في النشرات اللاحقه شكرا جزيلا لك
ميدانيا اصيب سته عناصر من القوات النظام
السوري نتيجه القذف المدفعي الذي نفذته
القوات التركيه على نقطه لهم في قريته
عقلنيه في عفرين في ريف حلب الشمالي كما
قصفت القوات التركيه مواقع اخرى تابعه
للنظام في قرى حربل وابيا وخريبكه
في ريف حلب الشماليه
[موسيقى]
اهلا جهاز الامن الوطني في العراق القاء
القبض على 94 شخصا متورطين في تهريب النفط
بحوالي 75 مليون لتر شهريا ومن بينهم ضباط
كبار
مراحل من خلال الضباط المتورطين والمنسق
او ما يسمى المندوب والمهربين
مهمه الضباط والمنتسبين المتورطين هي
تامين الحمايه للمهربين عند سحب النفط
الخام وكذلك تامين حركه الصهاريج
ومهمه المندوب هي اصدار البرقيات
والبوجرات الرسميه لحركه الصهاريج ويتم
اصدار البرقيات عبر دفع الاموال او تصدر
باسماء مصانع ومعامل وهميه
واما مهمه المهربين هي تسليم الاموال بعد
البيع الى المندوب الذي يسلمها الى الضباط
المتورطين وكلا حسب عمله
[موسيقى]
تحضيرات واسعه من ازمه الجوع وانعدام سهول
العيش في اليمن في ظل حكمه مليش الحوثي
اطلقها حقوقيون طبعا تحضيرات صدرت بعد
انتشار فيديوهات على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
لليمنيين وليمنيات وهم يزدحمون على بوابه
احد المطاعم للحصول على وجبات مجانيه
ناشطون حقوقيوننا حملوا مسؤوليه الازمه
الحاليه لميليشيا الحوثي التي اوصلت
اليمنيين الى الفقر والجوع والعوز في سبب
الفساد والانتهاكات التي ترتكبها
الميليشيا تحذيرات الحقوقيين تزامنت مع
اعلان الامم المتحده ان نحو 25.5 مليون
يمني يعيشون تحت خط الفقر في حين توقعت
التقارير الدوليه تصاعد الصراع والازمه في
اليمن بسبب عدم التزام ميليش الحوثي
بتجديد الهدنه ما ينزل بنجاح
[موسيقى]
التقى القائمه باعمال الممثل الخاص للامين
العام للامم المتحده في افغانستان
ماركتزيل بنائب رئيس وزراء حكومه الطالبان
مولاوي عبد السلام حنفيذ وذلك في كابول
لمناقشه قرار حظر عمل النساء في المنظمات
غير الحكوميه بالاضافه طبعا الى تدابير
اخرى من بينها منع النساء من الالتحاق
بالجامعات قالت بعثت الامم المتحده ان
قرارات طالبان تمنع وصول المساعدات
الحيويه الى الرجال والنساء والاطفال كما
اثارت مخاوف من حرمان الافغاني من الحصول
على الطعام والتعليم والرعايه الصحيه وذلك
في الوقت الذي يحتاجه نصف سكان افغانستان
الى مساعده انسانيه عاشله
طبعا حرمان تدريجي من ابسط حقوقهن مارسته
وحركه طالبان على النساء الافغانيات لعلى
اكثرها قهرا لهن كان الحرمان من التعليم
الجامعي غير ان بعض الشابات تخلينا عن
الخوف وتمسكنا بهذا المطلب بينهن الفتاه
عادله البالغه من العمر 18 عاما والتي
نظمت احتجاجا منفردا امام جماعه كابول
اقرا هي لافتتها الوحيده لكن حتى هذه
اللافته اخافت مسلحي طالبان ليقدم احدهم
على تهديدها وعلى سحب اللافته منها وعلى
اجبارها على المغادره بعد 15 دقيقه من
احتجاجها المنفرج
هذا وقد استقبل الافغان اول ايام السنه
الميلاديه الجديده بانفجار عبوه ناسفه قرب
نقطه تفتيش في محيط المطار كابول العسكري
وفق ما اعلنته حركه طالبان مراسل العربيه
افاد نقلا عن مصادر مستقله ان الانفجار
اسفر عن مقتل 14 شخصا واصابه العشرات
بجروح متابعه
لنقاط التفتيش المكثفه في كابل العاصمه
بالقرب من مطار كابول البوابه الرئيسيه
لمن يريد مغادره افغانستان
مثل هذه الانفجارات التي تقع وسط الجماهير
ووسط العامه من الممكن ان تقع في مدن
متقدمه والتي تخضع لاجراءات امنيه مشدده
كامري وجارتنا باكستان واسباكستان وغيرها
من الدول
الافغاني العادي مغلوب على امره يامل بعد
كل تحول سياسي في البلاد ان يتحسن الوضع
الامني لكن اماله غالبا ما تتلاشى مع كل
هجوم جديد
سوف تستمر نعمل قريبا
ترجح المعلومات الاوليه وحيثيات الانفجار
بمسؤوليه الداعش عن العمليه خصوصا ان
السلسله التفجيرات الاخيره تبناها التنظيم
الانفجار هذا استهدف منطقه حساسه وفي اول
يوم من العام الجديد لوجهها رساله واضحه
لسلطات في كابول بان العام الجديد سوف
يكون محذوفا بمثل هذه العمليات عبد الله
نادر العربيه كابول
في التاسعه ولكن بعد قليل
رسميا كرواتيا تدخل منطقه شنغن وتعتمد
اليورو عمله لها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مجددا الى التاسعه ونكمل من
ليبيا حيث اعلنت هيئه البحث والتعرف على
المفقودين استخراج ثمانيه عشره جثه مجهوله
الهويه من مقبره جماعيه في السرك قالت
الهيئه في بيان ان فريقا من اداره البحث
عن الرفاه يستخرج الجثث وحصل منها على
عينات للتعرف على هوياتها قبل ان يتم دفن
الجثث مجددا يذكر انها تنظيم داعش كان
يسيطر على سرد خلال عامين 2015
و2016 قبل ان يتم تحرير المدينه بالكامل
من العناصر الارهابيه
[موسيقى]
السعي الى تشكيل ناديته اسيوي هو اتهام
جديد يسوقه زعيم كوريا الشماليه للولايات
المتحده ويجعله ذريعه اخرى لتدعيم تراسنته
النوويه كيم جونغ اون غماسه واشنطن في
انشاء كتله عسكريه جديده
بالنسخه الاسيويه من حلف شمال الاطلسي
اضاف ان الكتله الجديده يتم انشاءها من
اجل تعزيز التحالف والتعاون مع اليابان
وايضا كوريا الجنوبيه الزعيم الكوري
الشمالي ساخره من الخطوه المزعومه على
اعتبار ان الولايات المتحده قال بانها
ترتجف من الخوف والقلق من القدرات
العسكريه المتزايده ليبيونغ وفقا تعبيره
[موسيقى]
زعيم كوريا الشماليه شدد على ضروره مضاعفه
بلاده لقدراتها مؤكدا ان المهمه الاساسيه
لقواته المسلحه النوويه تتمثل بكبح احتمال
اندلاع الحرب وحمايه الاستقرار اما ثنيها
فمهم غير دفاعيه في حال فشلت طبعا الاولى
وهذا هو السبب وفقاكم جونج اون وراى طرح
مهمه تصميم وانت صاروخ باليس جديد عابر
للقارات ويسمح بشن ضربه نوويه انتقاميه
على الفور في حاله وقوع هجوم كم اكد كذلك
ان هيكل العلاقات الدوليه قد تحول الى
نظام الحرب البارده الجديده لافتا الى
تسريع وتيره مواصفه بالدفع نحو التعدديه
القطبيه الجنوبيه جاء سريعا حيث حذرت من
نهايه نظام جارتها الشماليه في حال قيامها
باي محاوله نوويه حتى على الوقت الفوريه
لتطويل قوتها النوويه والعوده الى مساري
نزع السلاح النووي سيول شددت على بناء
جيشها لوضعيه الاستعداد العسكري للرد على
اي استفزازات بالاعتماد على نظام ثلاثي
المحاور اي منصه الضربه الوقائيه والعقاب
الهائل والانتقام الكوري وهو برنامج
لاستهداف قياده الخصم في حاله الطوارئ
[موسيقى]
المزيد معنا من لندن روبرت فوكس محل
العسكري اهلا بك سيد روبرت بدايه هل
بالفعل هناك مؤشرات ومعطيات حقيقيه
وملموسه من توجه كهذا من قبل الولايات
المتحده لانشاء النيته الاسيوي الذي يتحدث
عنه كم
لا لا اعتقد
ولا هيكليه جديده بل ارى ان
القوه المتوسطه وليست العظمى كالصين
والولايات المتحده
وتصريحاته الاخيره وسلاحاته الاخيره ايضا
وتهديداته النفسيه
وهم يتعاونوا مع بعض
وهم لديهم قلق كبير مما يمكن ان ياتي من
في هذه اللحظه هناك همم تصريحات فعلا هي
عدائيه
سيد همم روبرت ولكن يعني المخاوف يبدو
بانها متبادله بهذا الاطار وبالتالي لماذا
يخرج بمثل هذه التصريحات همم قراءتك مثل
هذا التهديد الذي يتحدث عنه
اراه صعب جدا
فهمه
تهديد لكن علينا ان نفهم ان كم يهدد
بناء المزيد من السلاح والسلاح
الخطر
الصواريخ الهايبر سونيك
والقيادات في الولايه العسكريه في
الولايات المتحده لا يبدو انها تاخذ الموز
الموضوع بقلق كبير
وكما كما نراه من الجهات الاخرى ف
تجارب صاروخيه الاخيره
قالوا انهم رؤوها من قبل ولكن الامر
المثير للاهتمام هناك
كبيره في اطلاق الصواريخ من كوريا
الشماليه بانواعه وسيارات المختلفه نحو 80
صاروخ
في
منطقه همم اصيل
وهي بالمستوى الاعلى حتى الان وبالتالي
كيف نتوقع ان يكون الرد الفعل الامريكي او
التعاطي مع هذا الملف بصوره عامه ولا احد
يجب ان ياخذ ايضا التوعد الكوري الجنوبي
على محمل الجلد
دبلوماسيه فاعله حول هذا الامر الامر
المقلق
اه اه الاخير من
التجارب وهو خمس مشيرات
من كوريا
اطلقت والدفاعات لم تتمكن من التعامل مع
هذه المسيارات
[موسيقى]
ان الخطر الذي تشكله يجب ان يتعامل
الجواهر وخاصه الصيني
[موسيقى]
فيتنام واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه هم من
عليهم ان يكون لديهم كلمه في هذه المساله
المس الخطر هو ما يحدث في كوريا الشماليه
بحديثها نعم ولكن سيد روبرت اذا ما تحدثنا
على ملف الورقه النوويه ليست كوريا
الشماليه وحدها التي تتحدث عنها روسيا
ايضا فرضتها على الطاوله وبالتالي ربما
يكون السؤال الان من هو الاقرب لاستخدام
هذه الورقه من غيره كوريا الشماليه او
موسكو
لكنني لا
استطيع الدخول فيه دهن همم كن ولا بوتن
وكلاهما
يفكران
بالخيار العسكري الذي الخير النووي عفوا
الذي قد يزعج الغرب والولايات المتحده
ولكنه ايضا يغضب القوى الاقليميه مثل
الصين اولا وكذلك
خطوات للتعامل مع هذا الخطر وخاصه مع ان
الامور اصبحت اكثر استقرارا
طيب من لندن روبرت فوكس المحلل العسكري
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
حضر صندوق النقد الدولي من ان الاقتصاد
العالمي سيشهد وضعا صعبا في 20 23 وقالت
مديره صندوق النقد الدولي اكستانينا
جورجييفا ان عام 20 23 سيكون صعبا على
معظم الاقتصاد العالمي خصوصا مع ارتفاع
حالات الاصابه بكرونا في الصين واشارت
جورجييفا الى ان نصف الاقتصادات الاوروبيه
ستدخل في ركود كما توقع صندوق النقد
دخولات الاقتصاد العالمي في ركود خلال 20
بلد المنشا انصحها التعبير لاحدى اكبر
الكوارث الصحيه الحديثه طبعا وفقا
للالاتهامات رفع معظم القيود الخاصه
بكرونا وتهيا لازالاتها تماما بعد سبعه
ايام لكن رحله السنوات الثلاث الماضيه لم
تكن سهله على الصين التي تاثر قطاعها
الصحي وكذلك الاقتصادي وهذا ما اقر به
رئيس هيئه لاول مره بحسب صحيفه وول ستريد
جورنا الاكدتشي التمسك بالامل واصفا
تحولات السياسه الوبائيه بانها محاوله
للتكيف مع الفيروس المتطور وقابليه
الانتقال العاليه غير انها القيود وعمليات
الاغلاق والحجر الصحي الاجباري اغرقت
مستشفيات الصين بعشرات الالاف من المصابين
واثقلت كاهله قامها الطبي مجددا مع بقاء
الارقام الرسميه المعلنه دون الواقع
باشوات قله الشفافيه هذه وايضا افتقار
بكين المعلومات الشامله حول عدد الاصابات
المسافرين الصينيين لمربع كورونا الاول اي
بدايه عام 2020 المسافرون من الصين
يواجهون قيود عند دخول اكثر من 12 بلد من
بينها الولايات المتحده نتحدث ايضا عن
فرنسا وايطاليا مجددا تقديم اختبارات
سلبيه مطلوبه منهم قبل الوصول الى
مطاراتها او الخضوع لاختبار عند الوصول
فيما اعلن المغرب حضر دخول المسافرين
القادمين من الصين على اراضيه اعتبارا من
الثالث من يناير لتجنب موجه جديده من
العدوى بالفيروس والحمايه من متحورات
محتمله وصفات منظمه الصحه العالميه هذه
الاجراءات الاحترازيه بانها مفهومه في نقص
المعلومات حول الموجه الحاليه من الوباء
بكيا
[موسيقى]
هذا واحد فرنسا دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
الاخرى على اجراء اختبارات للمسافرين
الصينيين للكشف عن فيروس كورونا بعد ما
قررت باريس اجراءها في ظل التفش الواسع
للجائحه في البلاد
[موسيقى]
القطع الشرطه العسكريه في البرازيل القبض
على شخص يحملوا جهاز متفجر وسكين حاول
دخول منطقه تنصيب الرئيس البرازيلي الجديد
لولاده سيلفا وذلك قبل دقائق فقط من بدء
حفله تنصيب الرسميه
بحسب ما اورده الشرطه العسكريه
بعد عقود من استخدامها تودع الولايات
المتحده شبكه الجيل الثالث وبشكل نهائي
جاء ذلك بعد اعلان شركه فيرايزن للاتصالات
انها ستتخليها رسميا عن الشبكه بهذا اصبحت
هذه الشركه اخر الشركات الامريكيه التي
قدمت على هذه الخطوه واوضحت الشركه
للمستخدمين الذين تعمل هواتفهم بتقنيات
الجيل الثالث فقط ان الخدمات ستتوقف ولكن
سيكون بامكانهم اجراء اتصالات برقم
الطوارئ او بمركز خدمات الشركه
[موسيقى]
لقي مهاجران مصرعهما وتم انقاذه مئتين
اخرين عندما غرق قريبهم قبله الساحل
الشمالي للبنان حيث تقوم اعداد متزايده من
المهاجرين بالرحلات المحفوفه بالمخاطر
للفراري من الاقتصاد المنهار في كل من
سوريا ولبنان
نحن عايشين هون
انا واحد الناس بدي ارجع بدي اسافر انا
كنت رايح مع اخي بس انا بتامنت مع المصاري
لحتى اروح مع اخي نحن بدنا نطلع الاوربيه
اليوم او بكره او بعد شهر او بعد شهرين
بدي اسافر
[موسيقى]
دخلت كرواتيا منطقه تشينجان الاوروبيه تمت
ازاله الضوابط مع سلوفينيا لتنضمه الى 22
دوله في الاتحاد الاوروبي والدول الاخرى
في منطقه شنغن
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
الدفاع روسيه
استخباراتوا المانيا تحذر مواطنيها ذوي
الاصول الايرانيه من عواقب وخيمه في حال
السفر لطهران
[موسيقى]
النوويه وكوريا الجنوبيه تاهب لحرب
المحتمله
فلاش
يصدموا العالم عام صعب ينتظره الاقتصاد
هيما مع اصابات كورونا في الصين
التاسعه انتهت الان مباشره الى ظهر 360
ظاهره تفضل شكرا
[ضحك]
المزيد من التقطيع الاحتفالات
العراق ماذا بعد في هذا الملف
[موسيقى]